ah
you know after a hard day of theorizing
it's good to just kick back and watch
some paw patrol with my son no deeper
meanings to analyze just a fun loving
show about puppies so simple so
wholesome oh hold on are these are these
puppies dead oh it's happening again
hello internet welcome to film theory
ruining your childhood since 2014. but
you know what i'm not content to just
ruining your childhood oh no i've got my
sights set on your children's childhoods
too today we're breaking new ground by
looking at shows that the kids are into
these days and my kids i mean the
three-year-olds specifically my son
oliver yep it's another installment and
my kid asked me to watch this and now
you have to suffer through the
consequences my three-year-old is
programming a 10 million subscriber
youtube channel without even realizing
it they just grow up so fast now
admittedly i actually really like this
show the paw patrol is a team of six
puppies led by a 10 year old boy named
ryder each pup has a specific set of
skills based on emergency services
there's chase the police officer dog
marshall the firefighter sky the
aviation dog rubble the construction pup
zuma for water rescue and rocky for
garbage collection every once in a while
you have a special guest dog make an
appearance like everest the mountain pop
or liberty the city pup but for like 90
of episodes this is our core team and
from there each episode is pretty
formulaic they're hanging out in the
city of adventure bay there's some
disaster like a windmill breaks or
someone gets stuck in a cave the paw
patrol are called to action they suit up
we hear this line ready for action
riders sir there's a mission brief they
slide down and load up into their
specially designed pup mobiles
[Music]
and through some combination of skills
the day is saved and a lesson is learned
usually the lesson for me is that a
shocking amount of problems can be
solved using a winch i'll need you to
use your winch chase i'll need you and
your winch i need your winch get your
witch out chase also the more you watch
the more it becomes clear that they had
no idea what to do with some of these
pups marshall with his fire rescue
equipment total mvp rubble with his
construction tools best boy zuma the
water dog meanwhile
yeah you can sit this one out buddy and
the next one and the next one you know
what just just pose for the lunchbox to
be honest this is one of the more
bearable kids shows out there because
it's self-aware and uses the formula for
some really solid jokes like here when
aliens come to visit adventure bay a
whole can of worms i feel like i should
probably unpack at some point but not
today it slides down the lookout tower
and launches into its vehicle like the
pups do in each and every episode only
here because the formula demands it it
also gets its name shouted out
it's a nice touch then you got stuff
like this when construction dog rubble
gets trapped the only one available to
drive his rig is zuma
we need his truck to move the rest of
the rocks once we get him out zuma uh
on the double and he just proceeds to
fail zuma is just the butt of all jokes
sure the whole thing is designed around
some very obvious merchandising
opportunities but just look how cool
this thing is i gotta get one for ollie
um uh we gotta get one for ollie but hey
at least the show is aware of this fact
officially licensed paw patrol
merchandise this stuff sells like
hotcakes it's funny cause it's true
isn't that right chase oh [ __ ] that's
right matthew
now the show already comes pre-packaged
with a lot of really obvious questions
how come the dogs are the only animals
that can talk why doesn't adventure bay
have a normal police force or fire
department when is katie finally gonna
admit that she has a crush on ryder
admittedly the last one might just be me
but it is so obvious that they would
make a total power couple anyway those
questions aside there was one moment
that really stood out to me a moment in
season one that caught my attention as
just a little bit weird and it prompted
me to dig deeper and oh boy did that
start leading me down the darkest
possible path for this universe one that
convinced me beyond a reasonable doubt
that the paw patrol is dead and not in
just a oh this was a dream route or
anything like that i'm saying that
within the canon of the show paw patrol
members have died and actively been
replaced so strap in all your good pups
cause this one is gonna be a rocky ride
ready for action rider sir cause matpat
is on the case so the moment that got me
to start digging deeper was from season
one episode 9a
pups get a rubble where we learn about
how rubble the construction pup came to
join the paw patrol now this is actually
one of the very few origin stories that
we get for any of the pups the only
other one that we see is for chase in
the paw patrol movie which i'll come
back to later in this episode we learned
that rubble was actually the last member
of the team to join basically he was a
stray puppy that needed to be saved
after the paw patrol rescues him he
winds up tagging along on their next
mission to rescue a snowboarder trapped
on a snowy mountain when rider shovel
can't dig up the snow baby rubble steps
in to save the day that bravery winds up
earning him a spot on the team he
receives his signature pup tag hard hat
and construction vehicle cue the end
credits you're all good
hold on look closer at what happens in
the episode ryder calls the pups to the
lookout for the mission briefing which
he does all the time but check out the
big screen do you notice the pup tags
along the bottom fire is marshall the
star represents chase and the police
force recycling is rocky the propeller
is sky the anchor is zuma but seriously
for as little as it's used it might as
well not be there and of course the
wrench is for rubble but
this is the first time that we've met
rubble he was literally just saved by
the team less than an hour ago but he
has a dog tag on the screen a tag that
he won't get until proving his worth at
the end of the episode his yellow
segment is also already on ryder's pup
pad how could it be there if they don't
have a construction pup yet the only way
that this makes sense is if there was a
construction pup prior to rubble now
you'd be forgiven for thinking that this
is an animation error or something but
the evidence proving that there was a
pup prior to rubble really starts to add
up once you look for it at the end of
the episode we see ryder give rubble his
construction helmet but if you look
closely at the helmet it has scrapes on
it as though it's been used this isn't a
brand new helmet for a brand new
profession within the paw patrol this
helmet used to be the last construction
pup's helmet rubble is also given the
construction rig which also has wear and
tear on the front of the bulldozer
portion see that paint wearing away
again it's been used before more
noteworthy though is the fact that
rubble's too small for the vehicle and
ryder explicitly says that he's gonna
need to grow first before he can truly
reach the wheel you have a little bit of
growing to do before you can reach the
steering wheel but you'll get there all
the other pups have vehicles that fit
them perfectly in fact when other new
pups join the paw patrol like everest
tracker and liberty their gear fits them
perfectly the first time so ryder is
clearly capable of making gear that fits
rubble when he's small but he doesn't
why it must be some sort of hand-me-down
he already had the equipment from the
last construction pup available why make
a whole new vehicle if there's a
perfectly good one sitting there waiting
to be used and again if you think i'm
looking too far into this here is the
definitive proof that i'm right you'll
notice that each vehicle is numbered
ryder's atv is one cause he's the leader
chase is two marshal three sky four
rocky five rebel six and zuma seven but
did you notice a problem with that we
know out of these pups that rubble is
the last to join the team because during
his story we see all the rest of the
team and yet here's his pup mobile
number six of seven this is proof that
there was a puppy before rubble doing
his job the numbers do not lie zuma
being number seven proves it hey would
you look at that zuma is finally useful
for something the more you look the more
evidence you start to see of a former
paw patrol one that's no longer with us
one that no one speaks of in season 1
episode 6b marshall attempts to break
the record for the fastest fire pup the
implication here is that some dog held
the record before him but who what other
fire pups exist in this world no
municipality outside of adventure bay
really seems to use anything similar to
a paw patrol in the paw patrol movie for
instance we start off with a semi truck
driving off a bridge when captain turbot
mentions the paw patrol the truck driver
has no idea what he's talking about he's
in shock when a puppy comes to rescue
him call the police call the fire
department
call everybody you're an adventure bay
here we call the paw patrol
you're gonna call the who same thing
happens at nearby adventure city when
the news actively reports on the arrival
of the pups guardians heroes cute little
dogs and adorable outfits whatever you
call them the paw patrol were here to
save the city the idea of a team of
rescue dogs just isn't a normalized
thing in this universe which suggests
that there was a marshall before
marshall to be the record-setting fire
pop in fact take a look at the fastest
fire pup trophy it looks exactly like
marshall's fire engine except marshall
doesn't have the record same vehicle
different pop just like we saw with
rubble but that's when you start to
notice a really disturbing trend all the
pups are stray dogs they're sad they're
scared and they're alone then and only
then are they enlisted by ryder we just
covered rubble's origin story where he's
a baby puppy in danger but the same
actually holds true for chase the police
dog in fact that's pretty much the main
plot of the paw patrol movie chase's
origin story is that he's a puppy that
was abandoned on the street by his
owners he's almost hit by an oncoming
car when suddenly he's rescued by rider
and recruited onto the team i know
you saw me and took pity on me
not at all i chose you because you were
the bravest pup i'd ever seen later that
same movie liberty is added to the team
another stray dog that we see roaming
the streets begging for food how's the
fruit business tony well it'd be better
if i wasn't always giving you free fruit
in fact looking across pretty much every
origin story that we have for new
members onto the team it's always the
same a lone dog with no connections and
no home is enlisted to be a paw patrol
member mountain dog everest jungle dog
tracker yep they're the exact same way i
can't wait to meet them it gets kind of
lonely sometimes are you gonna stay
around here it would be great to have a
friend nearby i'd like to make you an
official member of the paw patrol
ryder collects abandoned stray and
orphaned dogs to add to his team why
well here's where it all starts to come
together the missing pups the new
additions to the team they're all
expendable that's why it's a rescue team
made of dogs ryder doesn't use the pups
for rescues because they're best suited
for the task he's using them because the
risk of losing a human life is too great
and having puppies perform the rescues
means minimum human casualties if a dog
dies trying to save someone from a house
fire or a rock slide they can be
replaced we actually do see this in real
life with avalanche rescue dogs when an
avalanche occurs dogs are sent out to
search for anyone buried under the snow
to dig them out unfortunately this means
that in some cases dogs might be hit by
the avalanche and not survive but this
also means that in the process they've
spared the lives of any humans that
would have attempted the rescue instead
and who could be more expendable than
lone stray dogs with no home wandering
the streets i chose you because you were
the bravest pup i'd ever seen no rider
be honest with yourself you chose him
because he was there because he was
unwanted and no one would miss him in
success he becomes a top tier rescuer in
failure he's just another forgotten
puppy that would have died on the
streets anyway and if he dies in the
line of duty well then he's celebrated
as a fallen hero he's the goodest of
boys and if there is any doubt that
these dogs are in danger just watch the
show situations get perilous in the
movie alone they're doing rescues at the
top of collapsing buildings a building
we're told is the tallest one in the
world and in the show sure some episodes
are like hey we just saved a frog or hey
we brought your school lunch back to you
in time but sometimes you have stakes
where dogs are hanging on by their teeth
from out of control hot air balloons so
how does any of this benefit ryder well
financially the cost must be far less
than employing several police officers
builders and lifeguards the dogs are
given treats as their payment at the end
of each mission meanwhile ryder gets to
keep all the cash for himself no wonder
he always reminds people no job is too
big no pup is too small it's business of
course they'll accept any job the dogs
really can't say no and sure writer
attributes all the team's wealth to the
merch but government contracts tend to
pay even better this ten-year-old is
literally part of the
military-industrial complex and now he's
expanding the operation he's finding
dogs in new cities and setting up paw
patrol outposts around the world the paw
patrol will always look out for
adventure city in fact the paw patrol
movie shows characters from the tv show
actively commenting on the fact that
only now is the paw patrol becoming more
well known and to think i knew them
before they were famous it's a billion
dollar business built on the backs of
puppies pups that are expendable pups
that are following in the paw prints of
other pups that came before them ones
that died in the line of duty and have
been swept away by history that is the
dark secret of the paw patrol whenever
you need a hand just yelp for help the
ones who should really be yelping are
the dogs yelp chase yelp rubble in this
series you're the ones who are in the
biggest trouble you just don't realize
it you know i might not end up talking
to ollie about this theory at least for
a while but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and
cut
[Music]
[Music]
you